for the honor of gays grayskull
hey everybody you should have realized i
was gonna find a reason to talk about
shira at least one more time
and i decided to do something that i've
done for a couple of shows the big one
being doctor who
and i put off doing it for anything else
because it is exhausting and time
consuming it always takes way longer
than i think it's going to but i want to
do it for this one i'm going to go
through
every episode of she-ra and describe it
in 10 words or less it's fun and that is
the point here these are not reviews and
some of these are going to be jokes and
not actually indicative of what my
actual feelings about any given episode
are this is just
for fun and then as a bonus at the end
of all this i'm going to give you my top
10 episodes of
she-ra i'm not going to do a bottom 10
as well because
well i really like all the episodes and
even a bottom 10 would still be really
good stuff
seems pointless let's keep it positive
so strap in
let's have fun hey adora
i'm sure this breakup will have no
lasting consequences
i wonder what flavor the pie will be
enter
the hippies frustrated groans
spiky hugs and adventure
wow science
mommy's watching you adora catcher's tux
is everything i didn't know i needed
successful rescue almost
kinda room for improvement super pal
trio assemble
ow my heart
the power of gay compels you
you defeated the bots and you've just
won more
bots swift wind will make you
love him meet your new lab partner you
need to watch her closely
oh plus 10 bonus to making me fall over
laughing
is there something wrong with us no
sweetheart
you are perfection hey it's the world's
least surprising backstory
post-dats just when you
think you're coping in strolls your
abuser
butch crush showdown a new challenger
has entered
catra if you'd listen to my girl you'd
be happy
self-destruction isn't cutting it let's
destroy
everything every fantasy show needs a
false reality episode
oh catcher you messed up this time
uh party planning sucks
enter double trouble
it's not shape shifters you need to
distrust
it's theatrical personalities
if you're not worried about glimmer
you're not paying attention
have you tried turning her off and back
on again
my girl's making a stand i'm so
proud making you laugh right before
punching you in the gut exhibit a in the
case for a seahawk not planning
anything huh the pie flavor was fields
and the scorfuma ship is born
another wholesome dad for the pile
punching depression
with robot fists
meet the worst gaslighting dom
ever ground control to major bow
one good thing is only a start
weren't they three sisters in the
original oh
yes
told you he was the worst gas lighter
the closest we'll get to she-ra
the musical cute helmets and therapy
pets
for the win oh my god that's so adorable
oh she's just trying to hug them with a
tank uh
not gonna lie people i'm kinda scared
you're worth more than what you can give
to other people
[Music]
now before i can tell you my top 10
episodes of she-ra first
i'm going to take a minute to talk about
this video's sponsor
this video is brought to you by renard
city chronicles now i've been sponsored
by renard city before and last time i
talked about the webcomic element which
was how the entire thing started out but
this time
i want to bring attention to the
publishing of the second full
printed issue renard city chronicles
liar revealed
we have mysteries to answer about the
destruction of a city
what's going on with some of the key
characters and all the fun that you've
come to expect from this series
issue 2 of bernard city chronicles is
out now and you can order it from
bernardcitychronicles.com and if you're
watching this video there's a pretty
good
sense that you like things that are fun
and a bit cartoonish
i think you'll find something to like in
this and now my top 10 episodes of
she-ra
number 10 the seagate it introduces a
bunch of my favorite characters
including
seahawk mermista and scorpio my girl
and it's just fun number nine white out
again
a lot of great scorpio material in here
but it also does a lot to
work on the dynamic between catra and
adora we also get drunkadora which
that's always great number eight more
mysteries
in some ways this almost feels like an
upgrade to a bunch of the stuff that i
liked in the sea gate it's mermister
really getting to just
own her own dorkdom despite her too cool
for school attitude and
that's wonderful
how are you doing that i practice at
home
number seven the perils of pika blue
first of all the fashion
love it the music excellent the humor
terrific and then the end
oh scorpio i'm the muscle oh
man this show hurts me so good number
six
once upon a time in the waste again yeah
now big emphasis on scorpio but this
episode's so important not just because
it's great in and of itself
but it shows that there is a possibility
that catherine
could be happy if she could just let
some things go so it makes it all the
more tragic when she can't
number five princess prom oh that tux
oh and everybody's look the dynamics the
banter
the tension the conclusion oh
yeah number four roll with it probably
the single funniest episode in the whole
thing
and also one that i'll point to like
this is how you do a character who isn't
the brightest thing
in the world but still make them work
because scorpio yes she's kind of dumb
but you know what
she also takes on shira and glimmer
single-handedly and wins
until more princesses show up that's my
girl
number three promise this one
again heartbreaking in the best way
to see how far down this hate rabbit
hole
catcher is prepared to go to avoid
taking responsibility for
anything she does number two
hero it's pretty impressive that
learning the backstory and the details
of the life of a character we've only
had hints of
and we don't even really get to know
fully properly hits this
hard number one heart yes i'm counting
both halves as a single thing
that's the thing i tend to do you know
how hard it is
to wrap up something as satisfactorily
as this does
oh gold absolute gold
and that's shira every episode in 10
words or less
my favorite 10 episodes hope you had fun
what are your thoughts on anything that
i've done with this uh whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments
let's talk about a bunch of stuff to do
as well of course i have a patreon which
supports me and ensures that the channel
is able to keep going and i'm able to
pay my bills
and there's links to other things
besides social media merch etc etc etc
no pressure though you don't have to
because end of the day folks
you are the council i just run the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
um
foreign